well unfortunately this has been a
problem that eight news now has reported
on several times over the years now it's
coming up again
uh pet rabbits that are just being
dumped in parks
school campuses golf courses yeah so
sally jaramillo spoke to an organization
called
bunnies matter rescue while they're
trying to help curb the problem
there's still a lot of work to be done
while many may know desert shorts as the
beautiful neighborhood with water
grass and landscape a rabbit rescue
group reports this area is now one of
many locations in the valley where
people end up dropping off on wanted pet
rabbits
we are swamped sandy hawkins with
bunnies matter rescue
says every day they see rabbits being
dumped
most likely connected to easter families
deciding not to keep the pet
they don't realize that bunnies are an
exotic animal
they lend they live between 10 to 12
years
so they're a lifetime commitment
unfortunately right now we're being
inundated with surrenders
people that have bunnies currently in
their possession and for whatever reason
they can't take care of them over the
past several years eight news now has
reported rabbits being dumped at places
like csn's west charleston campus near
the mental health
facility and floyd land park a bunnies
matter rescue volunteer
recently trapped rabbits at harold
brinley middle school near jones and
smoke ranch
we took in the mom she had nine babies
one was stillborn
and so now we've been taking care of the
mom and the babies while grassy areas
with a water source seem like a place
rabbits will survive
extreme heat can harm them too you think
you're setting them free
but they're going to become food for a
hawk or a coyote a reminder just because
it looks like a place where rabbits
could survive bunnies matter rescue
group says
it only takes a phone call to help
alleviate the problem reporting sally
jaramillo 8 news now